الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الهدوء عاد الى جبل
الروس في مزارع الشبعه على الحدود مع
لبنان بعد حاله التوتر التي شهدتها
المنطقه صباح اليوم واكد الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه استخدم وسائل لتفريق متظاهرين
لبنانيين قال انهم حاولوا تخريب عوائق
اقامها الجيش في المنطقه في الايام
الاخيره كما اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
عناصر من الجيش اللبناني في المنطقه وجهت
مدافع صاروخيه باتجاه القوات الاسرائيليه
ويفيد مراسلنا نقلا عن مصادر عسكريه
اسرائيليه ان اعمال التجريف التي جرت في
المنطقه كانت في الجهه الواقعه تحت
السيطره الاسرائيليه وبالتنسيق مع قوه
اليونيفيل الدوليه العامله في جنوب لبنان
كلنا ننتقل الى الياس قرام من القدس لنرصد
معه اخر ما تقوله الروايه الاسرائيليه عما
حدث وكذلك ابرز ردود الافعال
بالفعل ومزارع شبعه بالنسبه للجيش
الاسرائيلي هي ربما الخاصره الاضعف على
طول الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه التي
تمتد على مسافه تصل الى نحو 80 كيلومترا
على اعتبار بان الجانب اللبناني ما زال
يرى في هذه المنطقه اراض لبنانيه محتله
وحزب الله يرى في ان هذه هي المنطقه ربما
الوحيده القادر من خلالها على العمل ضد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فيما اذا اراد الرد
على اي عمل عسكري تقوم به اسرائيل سواء
كان ذلك على الاراضي اللبنانيه او يستهدف
عناصر لحزب الله مثلا على الاراضي السوريه
كما حدث في عام 2015 عندما نصب حزب الله
كمينا في تلك المنطقه لرتل عسكري اسرائيلي
وقتل جنديين اسرائيليين واصاب سبعه اخرين
وكما حدث بعد الانسحاب الاسرائيلي من جنود
بلبنان في عام عندما قتل حزب الله ثلاثه
من الجنود الاسرائيلي في تلك المنطقه
واحتجز جثامينهم حتى عام 2004 عندما تمت
عمليه تبادل الاسرى مع حزب الله من الواضح
بان هذه المنطقه منطقه حساسه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل واسرائيل ما قامت به في الايام
الاخيره من اعمال تجريف في المنطقه هو
استعدادا ربما لمواجهه قادمه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بانه اراد ان يبرز
المنطقه الحدوديه هناك وان يحدد خط
الانسحاب او الخط الذي تسيطر عليه اسرائيل
في تلك المنطقه كي لا يحدث هنالك اي لبس
بين الجانبين في اين تمر الحدود او اين
تمر الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها اسرائيل هذا
من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى راينا في الصور
الوارده من هناك بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
اقام خنادق وحفر خنادق في تلك المنطقه كما
يبدو بانه يتحضر لتحسين المنطقه عسكريا
بشكل كامل مخافه وقوع مواجهه مع حزب الله
في لبنان
وللحقولي دون اي عمليات التسلل سواء كان
ذلك سيرا على الاقدام او عبر مركبات
الخطوره التي يراها الجيش الاسرائيلي فيما
حدث اليوم على الحدود مع لبنان يتمثل بان
قوات من الجيش اللبناني وصلت الى المنطقه
ووجهت اسلحتها وتحديدا مدافع صاروخيه من
طراز ار بي جي باتجاه القوات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي وجدت في المكان وقمعت
المواطنين اللبنانيين الذين قالت بانهم
اخترقوا
الخط الحدودي في تلك المنطقه وهي ردت
عليهم باطلاق وابل من قنابل الغاز المسيل
للدموع الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه عمل في
تلك المنطقه في الاراضي التي تقع تحت
سيطرته وان ذلك جرى بالتنسيق مع القوه
الدوليه العامله في جنوب لبنان قوات
اليونيفر لكنه من ناحيه اخرى هو يحمل حزب
الله المسؤوليه الكامله عن ما جرى وهو
يقول بانه هو من حث المواطنين اللبنانيين
على القيام بهذا
الاستفزاز
على الحدود ولكن اذا عقدنا مقارنه مع
المرات السابقه وبالخصوص في هذا السياق
المتوتر الذي تاتي فيه هذه
المناوشات ان صح وصفها كذلك ما الفرق
هذا الوضع هو ربما يكون اعتياديا كما يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي لكن ما من شك في انه
يحمل في طياته الكثير من التوتر تخيلي
مثلا لو ان الجيش اللبناني تدخل عسكريا
واطلق نيرانه باتجاه القوه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه فان المشهد كان سيختلف كليا
نحن نشير الى انه في العام 2010 كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يكون في موقع اخر على الحدود
ليس تحديدا في مزارع شبعه في عمليه تجريف
وصيانه للسياج الامني تحديدا في الثالث من
اغسطس من عام 2010 القوات اللبنانيه
اعتقدت بان الجيش الاسرائيلي اخترق الخط
الازرق في تلك المنطقه ودخل الاراضي
اللبنانيه فقام باطلاق النار باتجاه القوه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه مما ادى الى مقتل
ضابط واصابه اخر بجروح وادى هذا ايضا الى
رد فعل من جانب اسرائيل كاد ان يدهور
المنطقه الى مواجهه شامله لكن تحديدا في
مزارع شبعه المساله مختلفه تماما ذلك ان
هذه المنطقه من وجهه النظر اللبنانيه
وتحديدا من وجهه نظر المقاومه اللبنانيه
حزب الله هي منطقه محتله وبالتالي بامكانه
للحزب ان يعمل عسكريا ضد القوات
الاسرائيليه موجوده هناك من